when I was a boy heaven was here and
America was here you could be anything
you could do anything I never wanted
anything as much as I wanted to be an
American heart here in Pittsburgh are
broken over the loss of Hall of Famer
Mike Webster who had in recent years
suffered from mental illness and slipped
into financial ruin why does an
apparently healthy favorite son of this
city die in disgrace at 50 I can tell
something is wrong in 25 years I've
never requests a test like this what are
you looking for my god
I am the wrong person to have discovered
this if you don't speak for them
repetitive head trauma chokes the brain
it turns you into someone else take
needles vicodin toradol whatever it
takes to keep them in the game
it's business you got me a meeting with
the commissioner they don't want to talk
to you the NFL is knowing about the
concussion issue for years they're
terrified of you you're going to war
with a corporation that owns a day of
the week this is bigger than they are
they have to listen to us now where is
the science coming from from nowhere you
continue to deny my work your men
continue to die
they want you to say you made it all up
they're accusing you of fraud drop it or
they'll be doing me your autopsy mister
mama dr. Omalu you have no idea how bad
this could yet I have to keep going
these men are not machines we must honor
our warriors do you understand the
impact of what you are doing tell the
truth tell the truth I think you're
gonna be an American Hero
you're not even an American that's even
better
Birkin bag with luggage - that's well
don't tell me not to do a special here
at Milan film star shaft from $1000 on
part of an Besson there he is